hello I'm gonna stuff your credit guy
remember it so you don't have to well
with the premiere of The Walking Dead
coming back on AMC people have been
roaring with excitement
a rather mopey everyone's pumped up to
see their favorite non dead entities
come to life and try to kill our main
characters once more which of course has
me asking the question why does
everybody love zombies right now I mean
granted it's not like there was a time
when zombies were not popular it's not
to say where exactly the idea for them
started but many make the strong
argument that it originated from
Gilgamesh when Ishtar promises she will
let the dead go up and eat the living
and the dead will outnumber the living
since then there's been variations of
this idea from Frankenstein to I am
Legend he'll even Jesus is kind of a
zombie just replace eating brains with
teaching love and forgiveness
it still works but the zombie archetype
that most people are familiar with came
alive in 1968 with Night of the Living
Dead because of the film success and
long-lasting impact people often look to
this as sort of the Bible of zombie
stories it's what they always reference
when they want to do something zombie
related and indeed it's hard not to see
the similarities that inspired in future
zombie projects zombies are often slow
they look like walking corpses if you're
bitten by one you become one yourself
and they look to feed on the living for
the rest of their days which of course
makes you wonder how they procreate
seeing how they feed on people and not
just bite them I mean does that lead to
the person you just ate will become
alive in your stomach because
technically you fit them too regardless
the zombie formula has been established
for a while zombies gentlemen at times
like these our capacity to retaliate
must be
Lock and Load huh thanks to films and
other media like I am Legend 28 days
later Shana the dead zombie land and of
course The Walking Dead zombie seem to
be everywhere right now movies TV
conventions video games there's even a
Zombie Walk that takes place in most
major cities because if we won't raise
aaahm be aware in this dammit who will I
mean apart from the zombies tearing you
apart but that doesn't go so what is it
about now that makes zombies such a hot
topic I'll be honest I never found the
idea of zombies that interesting or even
really that frightening so what was I
missing that everybody else seemed to
love well of course there's the classic
scare tactic and that something is
trying to go after you but the heck
there's a lot of other different
monsters that do that like vampires
in fact the vampire craze seems to
finally be dying down a bit so in a way
I guess it makes sense that similar
fanbase would want to find something
along the same lines to gravitate
towards and zombies are definitely more
gruesome and more intense at least in
comparison to how both have been
reasonably portrayed you can show a
vampire without blood and no he's still
a vampire but with zombies you have to
show the gore no matter what it's not a
true zombie unless you have some body
parts or something falling off something
disgusting so maybe that fanbase growing
up is looking for something more extreme
in hardcore there's also a lot of
creativity that can be had with their
design at first you may think no come on
they all kind of look the same they're
just walking dead bodies that's it but
really think about it how gory can they
be what body parts are missing how much
humanity do you want to see left or how
much do you not want to see left this is
one of the reasons there's so much fan
art of famous characters as zombies
because the possibilities are just fun
but in our questioning flaw from my
point of view is that zombies by design
are not very interesting characters
there are exceptions that alter the
formula like zombies and warm bodies but
for the most part zombies are moaning
brain-dead vessels that only thrive on
their hunger to consume the living so
there's not a ton of room for
development so with that said what is a
character wise that draws people to them
well zombies are one of the supernatural
monsters where the focus of the stories
and even the scariness
is not based around the core
attacking the people but rather the
people themselves zombie movies show
what happened when everyday people are
put in extreme apocalyptic situations
all technology and first world
privileges are suddenly taken away and
whatever you are deep inside will slowly
come to the surface we quickly find out
who's the survivors the victims the
heroes and the villains our animalistic
tendencies an instinct for survival take
over and the battle half the time is not
between the humans and the zombies but
between what we need to give up to
survive and what we need to fight for to
keep human we ask ourselves what will we
do in these situations is a right to
give up all kindness and survive with a
cold heart or is it a world not worth
fighting for and even more importantly
not worth creating would we shoot our
own mother in the head if it meant
saving yourself and others
Jesus this says a comedy right the Sun
up naturally leads to a lot of
commentary about society as well George
a Romero's after hitting it big with
Night of the Living Dead continue to do
sequels and reboots most of them trying
to put the zombies in different
locations seeing not only how different
cultures of people will act but also how
different environments can have an
effect on the zombies as well Dawn of
the Dead for example takes place in a
mall a world where people argue
productivity and advertising have turned
many people in the zombies already what
are they doing why do they come here
some kind of instinct memory what they
used to do this was an important place
in their life in shonda the dead
it actually takes him a while to realize
that zombie attack has even happened
most of the people are so drunk or tuned
out of their own world that's hard to
tell who's actually still living in it
but like I said before the one factor
that never grabbed me personally is that
I never found sabi scary
I mean don't get me wrong I see why
others can find them scary the gore and
obviously being chased by something but
just slow-moving moaners who seem pretty
easy to fight off never seemed all that
frightening it's all character study and
commentary aside is there anything about
zombies that's really pushing the
envelope in terms of how to be scared in
my opinion this is where something like
Walking Dead really shines through yeah
you got all the scenes where they're
running away from the zombie shooting
him in the head all that fun stuff
but in a couple other scenes you see our
main characters talking and once
while you'll see a zombie or two just
walking in the background after a bit
the main characters don't even notice
them and half the time they're not even
addressed they just sort of walk along
their merry way and never even glanced
at them some could consider these kind
of humorous moments and at times it kind
of is but then it hit me this is why
zombies could only really be scary in a
medium like Walking Dead seeing how it's
a TV series so much time has been
dedicated to it that they have gotten
used to it so much so that they don't
even turn to acknowledge them and you
realize that you've come to grips with
the idea that you live in a world that
is always trying to get you you can
never fully be saved you can never fully
let your guard down and this is
something that only a long period of
time can pull off this isn't like a
movie where you have an hour and a half
to two or three hours to establish the
characters and the scares and all this
is a show that's still going on and
because we've been with these characters
for so long and followed their journeys
we understand them acting so casually -
something that in any other environment
would obviously not be ignored but we
also know if we wait too long or let our
guard down at just the wrong moment
you'll never get that moment back again
and with all the various reactions to
all the various characters dying you
feel the loss you feel the hopelessness
and that's a different kind of horror
than a monster just chasing you it beats
you down and it slowly eats away at your
humanity to a point where you really do
question what you're fighting for and if
it's worth fighting for anymore it's a
different kind of terror that takes good
acting and careful writing to pull off
and shows like Walking Dead do exactly
that so I guess that does make zombies
unique because it's one of the few scary
creatures where the scares aren't
immediate they have to be earned through
time and patience this is something I
never really thought about until I
started watching this show and after
realizing it I did suddenly have a new
appreciation for zombies that I didn't
before not the idea of fighting the
terror but getting used to the terror
letting it slowly destroy whatever kind
humanity you have left inside you let
every bad situation just build on top of
each other like every one zombie can
suddenly build on top of each other so
like any subject matter there's always
going to be good ways of doing in
there's gonna be
ways of doing it but it's made clear now
that the reason zombies are so popular
is because we love the possibilities of
it our media has opened up more and more
to given characters time to develop
especially in our TV shows Game of
Thrones Breaking Bad Mad Men we're all
about characters right now and these
zombie apocalypse stories whether we
realized at the time or not are actually
great outlets for it we're seeing the
fun we're seeing the creativity and a
top of it all we're seeing the scares so
whether this is just a fad or something
that will last at the end of time
there's no denying that there's
something fascinating creepy and just
downright entertaining about zombies
you